what I want to do in this video is
revisit a little bit of what we know
about PI and really how we measure
angles and radians and then think about
whether PI is necessarily the best
number to be paying attention to so
let's think of a little bit about what I
just said so pi we know is defined and
I'll write defined as an as a triple
equal sign I guess you could call it
that way pi is defined as the ratio of a
circumference of a circle to its
diameter which is the same thing as the
ratio of the circumference of the circle
to two times the radius and from that we
get all these interesting interesting
formulas that you get in geometry class
that hey if you have the radius and you
want to calculate the circumference
multiply both sides of this really this
definition or this equation by 2 times
the radius and you get 2 times the
radius times pi is equal to the
circumference or more familiarly
familiar li it would be it would be
circumference is equal to 2 pi 2 pi r
this is one of those fundamental things
that you learn early on in your career
and and you use it to find find
circumference is usually or figure out
radiuses if you know circumference and
from that comes how we measure how we
measure our angles in radians once we
get to trigonometry class and just as a
review here so let me draw myself a
circle let me draw myself a better
circle so there is my well it's it'll do
the job and here is the positive x-axis
and let me make some angle here
I'll make the angle kind of obvious just
so that it so let me make this angle and
the way that we measure the way that we
measure angles when we talk about
radians we're really talking about the
angle subtended by something of a
certain arc length and we measure the
arc length in rate well the way I like
to think about it is the angle is in
radians and the arc length itself is in
radiuses which will you know which isn't
really a word but that's how I think
about how many how many radiuses is this
arc length that subtends the angle in
radians so let me tell you what
let me show you what I'm talking about
so this arc length right here if the
radius is R what is the length of this
arc length well we know from basic
geometry the entire circumference over
here is going to be 2 pi R right this
entire sub circumference that's really
by definition this entire circumference
is going to be 2 pi R so what is just
this arc length here and I'm assuming
this is a that this is 1/4 of the circle
so it's going to be 2 pi R over 4 so
this arc length over here this arc
length is going to be 2 pi R over 4
which is the same thing as PI over 2 R
or you could say this is the same thing
as PI over two radiuses radius this is
this is one of those you know not not a
real word but that's how I like to think
about it or you could say it sub 10 it
subtends an angle of PI over 2 radians
so over here paid theta is PI over 2
radians and so really when you're
measuring angles in radians it's really
you're saying ok that angle is subtended
by an arc of that has a length of how
many radius I or I don't even know the
plural of radius is actually I think
it's radii but it's um it's fun to try
to say radiuses radii actually me do
that just those no one says that Sal
you're teaching people the wrong plural
form of radius R a radii so this arc
length is PI over 2 radii and it sub it
subtends an angle of PI over 2 radians
we could do another one just just for
the sake of making the point clear if
you went all the way around the circle
so if you went all the way around the
circle and you got back to the positive
x-axis here what is the arc length well
now all of a sudden the arc length the
arc length is the entire circumference
of the circle it would be 2 PI R which
is the same thing as 2 pi 2 pi radii and
we would say that the angle subtended by
this arc length the angle that we care
about going all the way around the
circle is 2 pi radians
two pi radians and so out of this comes
out of comes all of the things that we
know about how to how to graph
trigonometric functions or at least how
we measure the graph on the x-axis and
also touch on Euler's formula which is
the most beautiful formula I think in
all of mathematics and let's visit those
right now just to remind ourselves of
how pi fits into all of that so if I
think about our trigonometric functions
remember if this was so on the
trigonometric functions we assume we
have a unit circle here so on the trig
functions this is the unit circle
definition of the trig function so this
is a nice review of all of that you
assume you have a unit circle a circle
of radius 1 and then the trig functions
are defined as for any angle you have
here for any angle theta cosine of theta
is cosine of theta is how far you have
to move in or the x coordinate of the
point along the arc that subtends this
angle so that's cosine of theta and then
sine of theta is the y-value sine of
theta is the y-value of that point sine
of theta let me make that clear cosine
of theta is the x value is the x value
sine of theta is the Y value and so if
you were to graph if you were to graph
one of these functions and I'll just do
sine of theta for convenience but you
could try it with cosine of theta so
let's graph sine of theta let's do one
revolution of sine of theta so and we
tend to label so let's do sine when the
angle is zero sine of theta is zero let
me draw the x and y axis just so you
remember this this is the y axis y axis
and this is the x axis this right here
is the x axis so when the angle is zero
we're right here on the unit circle the
Y value there is zero so sine of theta
is going to be right like that so let me
let me draw it like this
so this is our theta and this is I'm
going to graph sine of theta along the y
axis so we'll say Y is equal to Y is
equal to sine of theta in this graph
that I'm drawing
over here and then we could do well I'll
just do the simple points here then if
we make the angle goat if we did in
degrees 90 degrees or if we do it in
radians PI over 2 radians what is sine
of theta well now it is 1 this is a unit
circle has a radius 1 so when we get to
PI over 2 so when theta is equal to PI
over 2 PI over 2 then sine of theta is
equal to 1 so if this is 1 right here
sine of theta is equal to 1 if theta and
then if we go 180 degrees or halfway
around the circle theta is now equal to
PI theta is let me do this in any color
I'll do an orange
I've already used orange theta is now
equal to PI when theta is equal to PI
the Y value of this point right here is
once again 0 so we go back to 0 remember
we're talking about sine of theta and
then we can go all the way down here
where you could do this either it's 270
degrees or you could view this as as 3
PI over 2 3 PI over 2 radians 3 PI over
2 so this is in radians this right of
this this this this axis so 3 PI over 2
radians sine of theta is it's the y
coordinate on the unit circle right over
here so it's going to be negative 1 so
this is negative 1 negative 1 and then
finally when you go all the way around
the circle you've gone 2 pi radians
you've run 2 pi radians and you're back
where you began and the sine of theta or
the y-coordinate is now 0 once again and
if you connect the dots or if you'd
plotted more points you would see a sine
curve over just the part that we've
graphed right over here so that's
another application say hey Sal where is
this going well I'm showing you I'm
reminding you of all of these things
because we're going to revisit it with a
different number other than pi and so I
want to do one last visit with PI we say
look pi is powerful because or one of
the reasons why PI seems to have some
type of mystical power and we've shown
this in the calculus playlist is there's
is Euler's formula that e to the I theta
is equal to cosine of theta plus I sine
of theta this by itself is just to
create its you know it's just one of
those mind-boggling forms but it
sometimes looks even more mind-boggling
when you put pie in for theta because
then from Euler's formula you would get
e to the I pi is equal to well what's
cosine of pi cosine of PI is negative 1
and then sine of pi is 0 so 0 times I so
you get this formula which is pretty
profound and then you say ok if I want
to put all of the fundamental numbers
together in one I could add in one
formula I can add 1 to both sides of
this and you get e to the I pi plus 1 is
equal to e to the I pi plus 1 is equal
to 0 sometimes this is called Euler's
identity the most beautiful formula or
equation in all of mathematics and it is
pretty profound you have all of the
fundamental numbers in one equation
e aí pi 1 0 although for my aesthetic
tastes it would have been even more
powerful if this was a 1 right over here
because then this would have said look e
to the I pi this bizarre thing this
bizarre thing would have equaled unity
that would have been super duper
profound to me it seems a little bit a
little bit of a hack to add 1 to both
sides say oh look now I have 0 here but
this is pretty darn good but with that
I'm going to make well I'm not going to
argue for it I'm going to show an
argument for another number a number
different than PI and I want to make it
clear that these ideas are not my own it
comes from it well it's inspired by many
people are on this movement now the Tao
movement but these are kind of the the
people that that that gave me the
thinking on this and the first is Robert
Palais on PI is wrong and he doesn't
argue that pi is calculated wrong he
still agrees that it is the circuit the
ratio of the circumference to the
diameter of the circle that is 3.14159
but what he's saying is that we're
paying attention to the wrong number and
also you have Michael härtel the Tau
manifesto all of this is available
online and what they argue for is a
number called tau or what they call tau
and they define tau and it's a very
simple change from by they define tau
naught as the ratio as
of the circumference the diameter the
ratio the circumference to two times the
radius they say hey wouldn't it be
natural to define some number that's the
ratio of the circumference to the radius
and as you see here this pi is just 1/2
times this over here right circumference
over 2r that's the same thing as 1/2
times circumference over r so pi is just
half of tau or another way to think
about it is that pot tau is just 2 times
pi or if you I'm sure you probably don't
have this memorized because you're just
like wait I've spent all my life
memorizing PI but it's six point two
eight three one eight five and keeps
going on and on and on never repeating
just like PI it's two times pi and so
you're saying hey Sal you know this is
you know pi has been around for you know
for millennia really you know why mess
with such a fundamental number
especially when you just spend all of
this time showing how profound it is and
the argument that they make and it seems
like a pretty good argument is that
actually things seem a little bit more
elegant when you pay attention to this
number instead of half of this number
when you pay attention to tau and to see
that let's revisit everything that we
did here now all of a sudden if you if
you pay attention to two pi as opposed
to pi
or if you we should call it we pay if
you pay attention to tau instead of tau
over 2 what is this angle that we did in
magenta what is this angle we did in
magenta well first of all let's think
about it let's think about this formula
right over here what is the
circumference in terms of the radius
well now we could say the circumference
is equal to tau times the radius because
tau is the same thing as 2 pi so it
makes that formula a little bit neater
although it does make the pi r-squared a
little bit Messier so you could you
could argue both sides of that but it
makes the measure of radians much more
intuitive because you could say that
this is PI over 2 radians or you could
say that this is PI over 2 radians is
the same thing as tau over 4 radians and
where did I get that from remember if
you go all the way around the circle
that is the circumference the arc length
would be the circumference it would be
tau radii or it would be tau raid
would be the angle subtended by that arc
length it would be tau radians all the
way around is tau radians so that by
itself is intuitive one revolution is
one tau radians if you go only
one-fourth of that it's going to be tau
over four radians so the reason why
towel is more intuitive here is because
it immediately you don't have to do this
weird conversion where you're saying oh
you know divided by two multiplied by
two all that yours like look however
many radians in terms of tau that's
really how many revolutions you've gone
around the circle and so if you've gone
one fourth around
that's tau over four radians if you've
gone half way around that be tau over
two radians if you go three fourths
around that be three tau over four
radians if you go all the way around
that would be tau radians if someone
tell you went if someone tells you that
they have an angle of ten tau radians
you'd go around the egg you go around
exactly ten times so it'd be much more
intuitive you wouldn't have to do this
little mental math converting you know
the multiple just saying do I multiply
or divide by two when I convert to
radians in terms of pi know when you do
it in terms of tau radians it's just
natural one revolution is one tau Radian
so that makes and it makes a sine
function over here instead of writing PI
over two well PI over two you know when
you look at a graph like this like where
was this on the unit circle was this one
fourth around the circle was this was
this 1/2 and this is actually one fourth
around the circle you're right over here
but now it becomes obviously if you
write it in tau PI pie nut pie top PI
over two is the same thing as tau over
four pi is the same thing as tau over 2
3 PI over 2 is 3 PI I'm sorry 3 tau over
4 3 fourths tau 3 fourths tau and then
one revolution is tau and then
immediately now when you look at it this
way
you know exactly where you are in the
unit circle you're one fourth around the
unit circle you're halfway around the
unit circle you're three fourths the way
around the unit circle and then you're
all the way around the unit circle and
so the last thing that the I think the
strong PI defenders would say is well
look Sal you just pointed out one of the
most beautiful one of the most beautiful
identities or formulas in mathematics
how does tau hold up to this well let's
just try it
out and see what happens so if we take e
to the I II to the I tau that will give
us cosine of tau plus I sine of tau and
once again let's just think about what
this is
we tau is the Tau radians means we've
gone all the way around the unit circle
so cosine of tau remember we're just
we're back at the beginning of the unit
circle right over here so cosine of tau
is going to be equal to 1 and then sine
of tau is equal to 0 sine of tau is
equal to 0 so e to the I tau e to the I
tau is equal to 1 and I'll leave it up
to you to decide which one is seems to
be more aesthetically profound